*Sad Piano Pewds*
finally
FINALLY
A good Barbie game
*keem intensifies*
these are real tears
of joy
The gang is all here
We gotta-
we got a little kitty
is that Ken?
Token black girl?
Now I understand why Token's name is
Token in, in South Park.
We got Mexican girl and we gotta, horse?
it's so nice to see such a diverse
crowd in a video game
finally someone that doesn't discriminate.
I relate to horses you know
I wish i was a horse
and I'm really glad that finally I feel properly represented
in a video game
I also am
half palm tree
So that makes me double happy right now...
Are we ready to play this game?
I think no
I think you will never be ready to play this game
so here we go
I expect nothing better than crack cocaine.
*weird pewds gargle sound*
What is happening?
why is Ken's haircut--
I CAN MOOVE!!
Thought it was a cutscene
Oh my God, Barbie looks so beautiful
I feel like they're playing like three different
soundtracks at the same fucking time
and it's so annoying
uhh, whe-- where should Barbie go guys?
Let Barbie go to Ken!
Barbie: So Ken,
How's the BEST
boyfriend in the world?
*Ken* Great, now that you're here Barbie
*Pewds* Yes, he's trying so hard not to look at her cleavage.
Look at him.
*Pewds mocking Ken* Uhh- nah-- I was-- I-- I'm just looking at your uh- eyes...
they're so beautiful
don't look at her cleav-
don't look at don't look at a cleavage don't look at
*Pewds mocking Barbie* What's the matter, Ken?
you don't like me Ken? Are you not attracted to me?
Who the fuck are you then?
How long are you gonna tune that guitar!?
just play the Goddamn guitar.
It's tuned!
*Barbie* -Hi Ryan *Ryan* -Hey Barbie ;) how are you?
*Strums guitar*
UUH
"How are you?"
*Barbie* -Hey Ryan you up for game day?
*Ryan* Sure if you're there it's sure to be a blast
*Pewds* Gameday,
blast...
(out of tune guitar)
... they're talking about 'sexual intercourses'.
dISGUSTING.
Bleh
I'm scared
I'm scared of playing this game now.
alright,
uuh
ok we can change outfits.
I like that-- I like the outfit-
I- I don't have a problem with the out-
...yeah that's pretty fun
This is definitely so much customization
I can't decide I don't know why
yes...
all right idk why we did that
complete fucking waste of time let's go upstairs
Let's go upstairs everyone
hey yeah. Hello, how are you?
*Barbie* -Nicki! How's your day?
*Nicki* -I'm having a great one, Barbie, thanks!
*Pewds* Why do they feel so dead?
And why's it making me feel so dead?
*Barbie* -We're about to start a game! you in?
*Nicki* -Sure thing Barbie
Sounds great!
*Pewds* THEIR LIPS
DOESN'T MOVE
ITS 2017-- Oh wow--
It's the wide selection of minigames that I
can't play I'm really-- why- why is it
there then...
Where you going barbie--  barbie i can see you
Barbie get the fuck back here
asshole.
Corridor that doesn't go anywhere...
okay...
The credits. The credits, everyone!
*Barbie Game Music* We can take it eaasyyy at the dreeamm houusee
At the dreeam houuse *Pewds clapping off beat*
Can that fucking asshole stop tuning his GOD damn guitar
it's sooo annoying
*Pewds* WHAT DO YOU DO IN THE GAME?!?
OPTIONS!?!
WHY WOULD YOU GO ~UPSTAIRS~ FOR THE OPTIONS?!?
I'M A 26 YEAR OLD MAN AND I DON'T UNDERSTAND HOW YOU PLAY THIS GODDAMN GAME.
OH ok... you-tu-- uh, shut up shut up shut up
*Nicki Gasps* Wait-- is it...
Little Black Dress with Pearls?! :D
*Barbie* Yes! That's it!
*Nicki* ALRIGHT!! Team Nicki and Teresa!
in
the
house!!
Ugh, whateves, Charades is boring.
*Pewds* I can't... what is happening?
MY new Video Game!!
*Pewds* Oh my God yes...
WHAT WAS THAT!!!1!!1!!!!
WUUUTTT!!!
UUAAGHHHH
UUGGHHHH
SECERT BARBIE NAATZIII
hooohh my Gooood
I havn't felt this ALIVE.....
since 1984...
*Pewds out of breath* Where should we go bros...?
Where should we go....?!
The wardrobe...
The source...
Good choice.
*Robotic Voice* Step one...
Find. The. Hidden. Boxes. Of. Clothes.
Step two...
Put. Them. On. The. Right. Pedestals.
Is he trying to sound like a robot? or is he  extremely bored?
Like I can't. tell.
Ugghh my God yes...
Hell, to the yes...
Sorry, w--what was i supposed to do again...?
What the FUck?
That ladder just went stra-- straight though her...
Amazing...
amazin...
uhh, lemme check here...
I just have to click on everything...
Hey I found a present...
Could it be a PIZZA perhaps...?
*Buzzer*
...sorry...
All right we need to find one more thing I guess...
Just in case I wanted to change my outfit, I can do that WHILE i'm playin this game...
Nice--
Nice touch...
I think this minigame, I'll go with the PuRpLE dReSs... Thank you.
How am I supposed to find the other thing? like I'm extremely Bored and I don't wanna do this...
I found hers...?
You fucking asshole
She stole mine!!
Whats happening?
That was it?
I just gave it aw-- i just GAVE it AWAY???!
What was the fucking poooint?
Match the shoes, okay. So what goes with pink shoes??
Okay think FAST Felix, you got this!
shut up
OK
uh, we gotta go--
s-
sp-
p-
Stars
Th-ju--
Ah
Fuck
Fffuck
*Random* Woohoo!
*Pewds* Why my--
*Random* Teresa that was awesome!
*Pewds* Don't patronize me.
I don't need it.
Fuck you.
okay well this-
this-
this game is boring me to death
I'm sorry
I can't
I can't play this garbage.
*Barbie* -Yaaayy!
Midge is here!
*Midge* -I'm happy to see you too Barbie!
*Pewds* Is she calling her midget?
.....
no
Wait she has the same fucking VOICE as her!
*Barbie* -Yaaayy!
Midge is here!
*Midge* -I'm happy to see you too Barbie!
Shes talkin to HERSELF.
YYAAAAAYYYY
PEWDIEPIE IS HERE!
*Pewds #2* YAAAAAY
IT'S GOOD TO SEE YOU TOO PEWDIEPIE!!
*Pewds #3* YAAAAAA
*Barbie* -Midge, you adore games don't you?
*Midge* -Sure do!
playing games is totally groovy!!
i LoVe ViDeO gAmEz
*Sheen Esteves Impression* i PlAy CaLl Of DutY
eVeRy DaY!!
I got a care package the other day
it had your mama's ass inside.
oh
OH
Oh NO
I can't do it, the muuusic is too good
*Background Music* I can be anything I wanna be
If I can dream it, I can do it no one's stopping me
and I wiiillllllll
Yeah I wiiilllll
Oh my God not the cut scene I can't...
*Nicki* Is it, the little black dress with pearls?
*Barbie* Yes! That's it.
*Nicki* All riiight! Team Nicki and Theresa! In, the, house!
I think the animation is on- on par with the Zelda CGI
I gotta-- I gotta say
Its pretty good
Pixar...
You need to do better scouting cuz there's so much untapped...
Talent
out there
Especially the secret Nazi Heil
I really
That was great
I mean I don't-- I-- I don't approve of it...
Whatsoever
find it disgusting and discriminating
and very insensitive in times like these
that are...everyone ha-- is has having a really
rough time right now
*Robot* I. Am. Serving. Up. A. Challenge. Girls.
Search. For. The. Cake. Batter. And. Put. them. On. The. Pedestals.
In. The. Right. Order.
Who the fuck is that guy?
who is--
Who and why, is that guy a thing?
Couldn't they just have made a Barbie Game without all this shit?
If anything I would just want a full feature Barbie Movie
because the animation is so good.
This is the same game youu-- I'm playing the same Goddamn game
afhjkds-- It's-- is extremely boring by the Way
Look I found hers
Great
You're Welcome
Oh look she find mine
huh--
how 'bout that...
great I'll take it
no it's
Just fucking grab it
Fucking asshole...
That was not a salad
How did this salad become this?
What is--
WHAT IS HAAAAP!??!
Asian Lady has given up...
Aye I got
nope
Maybe I can block her...?
I'll block her from achieving her goals.
that's right
You ain't goin nowhere bitch
Where you going?
huh?
Where you goin?
Where you goin bitchh?
HA
You blocked bitch
Where you go huh?
Where you goin? I'm Barbie you don't fuck with me.
motherfucker she find her puddin...
Bitch find her puddin
I betta block
aw, son of a bitch got her puddin,
Muthafucka
HAIL
THAA
CUP
CAAAKEE!!!1
have a giant cupcake
AHHHH
Look at her face
*Squeaks from Pewds*
THE
CUP CAKE
I'm not a Barbie fan
Ha
By  the way
I'm not
IM not...
im not..
lemme pause it...
I am NOT a Barbie fan...
ok?
let that be clear
I am playing this game, ironically.
okay?
I don't actually
LIKE Barbie...
at all
not even a lil bit...
Not even a lil bit... I don't even like Barbie
...what is..?
*Narrator* Cupcake Explosion!!
*Faintly* what is happening...?
Why are we throwing cupcakes?
*Deep and Raspy* Aye Bitch
Eat a cupcake up!
OH!
*Porn Star Voice* You ripped that up, RRRachel
*Pewds* He needs to stop talkin...
What the fuck?
How did I do that?
MOOORE CUPCAAAKEES!!
hell yeah
it's like the bottle flip challenge
except MOOORE CUPCAKES IS COMING EVERYBODY!!
The right side clearly has an advantage
I don't appreciate it
This game is amazing
I wanna die with this game in my hand
between my buttcheeks
what the fuck
they're all bad cupcakes?
They're all bad cupcakes, don't touch them Barbie...
Don't fuckin tou-
Wait, wait, wait,
they're good cupcakes?
I don't understand are they bad cupcakes?
Or are they good cup--
I got 16
I didn't even get half
I didn't even get half of the third one
This is a kids game
no
no this can't be happening
I lost to those fucking bitches...
muthafuckas dead to me...
I'll Kill em...
I kill em...
Do I have to do this fuckin...
Can I not skip this part?
For the love of God can I skip this part?
*Robot* Step. One. Fu--
Step one
FUUUck
it's the same game it's the same game
it's the same...
*Narrator* Today's event takes place in Barbie's bedroom...
and look to be a real doozy called
Shoe box Sky Scraper
a-A-Ahhh shit, its a doozy
That's my box!
AHHH
Where the Fuck am I supposed to get the boxes?
*Narrator* It's not that bad Barbie
WEELLL IIIIIIII--
Hell yea Barbie...
you get him girl
Fuck
OH I get it, you have to press space
Hell yeah, all right now it's easy
good game
she's fucking me
kill
me
*Girl* Epic Fail!
Please don't say that word.
Please don't ever say that word.
*Girl* Awesoomee
With a capital 'A'
WiTh A cApItAl
I g-- I usually go all-- all caps AWESOME, but...
Hey I won
*Nicki* -I was in it, to win it
SHit I lost to her...
Barbies like...
*Deep and Raspy* YEAH
YEAH IT LOOKS LIKE I LOST THAT ONE...
BUT I...
BETTA KEEP...
SMILIN...
imma fuck dat bitch up later...
imma fuck dat girls boyfriend..
Alrite well that was
Barbie's Dreamhouse
definitely worth it.
Leave a like if you enjoyed watching
maybe I'll do a part two if enough people
like it so show your support and as always
Ha I can't do that joke...
BROFIST!